i brought a double date ladies it's my
uh co-pilot
ross matthew hi hi
because i just figured you know listen i
love being a third wheel but when a girl
is lucky enough to have a date like
rossie well i want to hang with my
rossignol that's right
i'm a dreamboat can't help it you
certainly are
anyway i wanted to play a fun game with
you guys that we're calling
ready if you did the crime you must sip
the wine
okay i'm gonna read some questions and
if you've done the crime then you must
take a sip of your delicious
fresh vine wine ready okay
yes okay we're ready all right and we
can all participate in each question
okay everyone first um take a sip if
you've ever
lied to a best friend um you kind
well actually if it's a surprise
birthday party that you're planning
you have to lie to your best friend oh
that's yeah
i had my friend cut bangs once and i
told her it was cute and they weren't
okay that makes sense
um okay take a sip if you've ever
regifted something
are you getting
this is so amazing take a sip if you've
ever sent a racy text
to the wrong person
[Laughter]
way too many times
okay here's the irony though is i'm i'm
not name dropping
um you two ladies are both in the same
um industry
uh my best friend happens to be cameron
diaz and i sent her a video
of me getting dressed and um
i sent it it turns out to a 16 year old
boy named matthew anyway
long story he then wrote me back and was
like
i have your video but i promise i won't
like put it out anywhere
oh my god and i'm only getting dressed
not to be sexy but i
am like doing this to her but it's um
it's because i was trying to multitask
and she's my best friend and we get just
in front of each other all the time so
anyway
all right um take a sip if you don't
love that story
you do if you know it yeah thank god for
matthew being such a kind young
gentleman not to put it out there in the
world
um okay take a sip if you've ever faked
it
oh god all right well what might you
would be referring to
you know it
drew i see you taken while i think about
it
that's another set i did it once just to
see what it was like i was i was like i
guess maybe this would just be a fun
time to try
what that's all about yeah like and it's
boring
really did you really sell it though um
i tried to i was like i wonder you know
i wanted to
do my best when harry met sally
impression yeah i totally would
not want to do that by the way we all
know how to fake it but i was like i
want to see if it works and convinces
this person i guess it's also a good way
to just
end it yeah let's wrap this up all right
if you've ever
take a sip if you've ever i can't
believe you're getting shy on this one
all right take a sip if you've ever
cleaned out a toilet bowl with an
ex-boyfriend's toothbrush and then put
it back for them to brush with
oh my gosh
i want to know who this expert wait
while you were dating them or after you
broke up
while we were dating um we were together
and um he deserved it
does he know um
i also sabotaged cake i made
him um i let the dogs eat it before
i served it okay
um i am obsessed with am i am i the only
person that's ever done anything like
this
the only person who's admitted it on tv
um
has anyone ever done anything like you
know to someone who might have wronged
you
uh you know in a relationship
no never yeah no no no
sorry spray painted an ex-boyfriend's
car in the middle of the night
we put on like you know balaclavas and
blasted cypress hill and then got out
and spray-painted like
his precious car um and uh
he was like someone sabotaged my car
last night
it wasn't you was it and i was like
uh-huh
we're learning a lot about you you can't
do that because of
instagram and cameras and all sorts of
things
too much evidence it's true this was all
in the 90s okay
let's take a sip if you've ever been on
the drew barrymore show and had a great
time
[Applause]
cheers we love you guys so much
and um be sure to get yourself a nice
bottle of fresh vine wine